all you'll hear is footsteps
and i'll just superman punch him across
the deck he'll do a backflip over the
camera
i can see him out over the past i could
see he will backflip over there
[Music]
yeah guys it's
monday fun day it's a fun day
and um
before we get into anything
first of all forgot to mention it on the
last episode i can't believe i let the
team down it's called patreon
oh you didn't mention it i forgot one of
the first episodes i think there's only
been like two or three episodes i've
never mentioned it patreon
that's where
your boys come together and produce that
uncut uncensored you know sometimes we
post stuff and youtube says you know
what guys we can't we can't allow you to
make money from that we just can't allow
it it's just too it doesn't block the
whole thing
there's two launchers saying we love
what the youtube obviously we got a
great relationship with youtube
sometimes they approach us and and
spotify as well and apple podcast we've
got a great relationship we're all
through all of the circles yeah yeah
we're all medium and they come over to
us and like guys obviously we get it you
guys are the second biggest podcast in
the world i know everyone stays shook
the charts stay popping your tick tock
stays viral always
but some of the stuff you guys talk
about we love it
but you know what you you know what
culture we live in at the minute exactly
you can get cancelled like that and we
can't let that happen so what we're
going to do is we're going to give you
the video back you just need to make
some chops and changes and then run it
back to us yeah and obviously we're vex
we don't want to do that to you man so
what we did is created a patreon page
right now every single thursday
every thursday without fail without fail
my g's you guys will get
some version of explicit sng original
content every thursday without fail
whether it's
live here in the studio whether it's on
zoom whether it's via telekinesis you
will
get that
on top of that
if you're willing to
if you're willing to cough up a few
extra more pennies
you can get yourself a discount on the
merch
your boys rocking that look i'll clean
this fam that character design look how
clean this is that's clean clean bro the
boy's got the gang gang it's a little
bit fluffy that's my fault but the gang
guy i walk around with the gang gang and
get so many compliments man don't even
know it's much exactly i don't even know
this is our [ __ ]
this is literally we invented this might
not even know about that
so guys if you want a little discount if
you want to get the episodes before
everyone else you know if you want to
see the
50 of the podcast that you're missing
that behind the scenes
that
youtube can't step in you know what to
do patreon lets you say what you want
you know what to do head on over
patreon.com
forward slash shits and gigs that's
where the party's at
jagged edge said it best they did head
on over have some fun
pour yourself a drink
and take a shot with us fam take a shot
with us we're continuously sip sipping
we are continuously sip sipping
and
you already know it's boogie yogi so
yeah head on over to patreon that's all
good guys if you
physically can't hang a hangout at
patreon or if you're you are a patreon
and you're just here for the monday
vibes
make sure you you you you click that
subscribe button you click the bell
notification i think sometimes when
we're talking about it and it's all
hahaha jokey jokey man will be there at
the laptop cursor's there and then ha ha
yeah yeah yeah subscribe to the channel
but they won't actually click it yeah no
they won't actually click
so i just needed to go one inch to the
right and
and there's a bell right next to it just
so that you know every single time that
we
exactly we drop drop drop
you're there first there's a certain man
in the comments that say first every
week every week they're racing to say
[ __ ] fam they're racing today's person
you man are just chilling like you don't
give a [ __ ] you're missing and we know
better than that we know you do give a
[ __ ] you guys give all the shits so
like subscribe comment chirps are ting
in the comments bro whether you're a
male or female or non-binary find a
spice in the comments and chirps them
secure a lips and let us know how it
went
um
and
last but not least guys
october 10th you know the vibes
bbe
podcasting agency we're so big a lot of
people think it's on the bbc
but this one
is for the bbe right bbe
podcast festival october 10th in london
have i forgot the dress again yeah i
know the postcode starts with n1 but
luckily
the links are in the description if
you're listening and the link is on your
[ __ ] video if you're watching right
now
right there so head on over to that
website
hopefully by the time this comes out you
guys
still have tickets left
there's none that we get to keep back
for secrets yeah we can't we can't hold
something back for you man that are late
when they're gone they're gone now if
you want to rock up anyway and just say
hi we're here for that
by all means um but yeah your boys will
be on there we'll be on there kind of
late i think it starts at two yeah i
think we're on for like
yeah we get like eight or nine maybe
nine i think
yeah so
get there when you get there but um your
boys
you said this last week you said this
afternoon your boys may be the headliner
yeah your boys may or may not be
headlining it's not confirmed it's not
written anywhere but
normally
if a massive duo comes on at the end of
a show
to me it sounds like i'm headlining fam
you know when man are asking
cool
when you shut down the thing
what color fireworks do you want going
off
it gives the impression
that it's the headlighting
that's the pic that's that's the
narrative that they're painting in it
i'm telling you that's the narrative now
we've got
big boy podcasts
on the lineup we have on the cool sheet
we have big boy podcasts all of them are
massive fam all of them are massive
but we didn't choose the rotor we didn't
choose how the temperatures choose the
lineup
did they look at our statistics and
think geez man should shut the thing
down maybe i don't know i wasn't in that
boardroom meeting skeptical we weren't
there we went there all we got was the
details we were just showing up we just
it was a favor
we were asked to just say hi
next thing you know what a 9pm slot
we're on the 9pm primo slot
[Laughter]
that's that's all that we know it's all
the information that we've been given
guys make it of it what you will but all
you need to do is head over to the
website links in the description link
should be popping up on your video
screen right now head on over there grab
yourself a ticket
spend that good good money and come say
hi we will be chatting to you we'll be
laughing with you
who knows like
you may get lips
if you're a sweet one
you might get lips you may get lipsticks
if we're doing it mediterranean style
that double cheek
drake said the better always [ __ ] up the
double cheek kiss you know you never
know it could pop guy or go you might
get lips
but anyway head on over guys it's going
to be a sick night um it's your boy's uh
first live show and we're super excited
um this is the start of big things to
come so yeah head on down
and uh yeah can't wait let us know when
you've got your ticket yeah mom um and i
guess that's enough waffling
straight into the fifa let's get into
the fifa fun fact
um right can you guess
there's two people can you guess the
only two footballers in the world
i think you might get one that have
scored in every minute
in a game so they've scored one minute
one two three up until nineteen until
ninety yeah wow there's only two
footballers in
current football that
have had that done how many guesses do i
get um you can get five five guesses
ronaldo
he was one of them
because i knew you'd get one
sedan
no but that was a good guess
um
not messy no no
bec not beckham no
that's four guesses
english or not english he's not english
hungry
no that's another good guess though i'll
give you that all right i'll give you
that that's another good guess it was
last time ibrahimovic really yeah
fam
to be fair i was watching some tick
tocks on him earlier randomly they
popped up
and there was one thing he um
he got tackled
and he grips donny he's too tall yeah
he's six five
he grips donny in the back of his neck
like this
like cupped it cupped it and donnie was
looking up at him and he wouldn't even
like i caught he wouldn't even look down
to make eye contact with him he got
tackled by him
clamped his hand around his neck while
he knew donnie was looking up at him and
just said [ __ ] and then like grabbed his
t-shirt and just moved him
and donnie was just
screaming oh my face is the city said he
cupped him like this i didn't look down
at him i was like oh my god there's
certain things in life where i realized
like i said i'm not a confrontational
guy yeah certain things in life i think
i don't care about my career i don't
care about anything you're taking no
one's doing this on my neck
grabbing me and going like that
oh
fat nose making eye contact won't even
look at me
oh blast your stinky little rat nose off
i don't care how tall you are
i'll throw it all out
these men love to push and shove yeah i
will crack your jaw
you would never couldn't leave it again
oh of course enough you would never
that's what i'm saying but that's when
i'm not convey i think a lot of the
reason why i'm not so
non-confrontational is because i not
like i have any anger issues or anything
like that but i have a tendency of like
it takes me
forever to get angry okay but if you get
me angry enough yeah
there's no way down you don't care about
the consequence oh i don't care
like it would take
so much to get me there to the point
where you're thinking oh james
potentially might be a mug because he's
just having it yeah but then once i've
passed that
i'm waking up in a cell
fam
ah and some of the disrespect i see i
was watching um
ramsay's kitchen nightmares okay i was
like in the old episodes earlier fam
there was one episode he went to spain
to help donnie with uh one donny with
his restaurant in spain on tapas joint
uh it was i wish it was a tapas drawing
bro it was some [ __ ] shake thing he
was coming up with his own recipes he
did like prawns and with a chocolate
sauce it was a joke the whole thing was
a joke bro that's horrendous anyway
as um he's going through that there's
one point donnie who's the restaurant
owner
was getting mad defensive okay gordon
seconded him and just basically said
like big man because i think he was in
like 50 grand worth of debt of his dad's
money his daddy invested it to help him
and he was in so much debt yeah and he
was like big man like you're just a
[ __ ] kid playing with daddy's money
like you're a [ __ ] that's what
gordon's golden saying that to him
i said everyone here's a [ __ ] joke
this is like the worst [ __ ] obviously
the same video is the worst [ __ ]
restaurant i've ever stepped in
if you don't pull your [ __ ] finger
out you're just gonna be [ __ ]
bankrupt and all this stuff and as he's
walking now
he has to step past the um
the restaurant manager
but he goes front to front so he has to
side step past him
so as he slides stepping past the
restaurant manager the restaurant
manager is looking up at him fam
he looks him up and down the restaurant
gordon looks the restaurant manager up
and says [ __ ] off and just walks out
i was thinking big man i don't care what
tv show this is
i'll knock you the [ __ ] out my blood boy
oh man looks him up and down like he was
a piece of [ __ ] and said [ __ ] off
i just walked out
fam i will sprint behind him grab the
back of his collar and he yanked him to
the floor
i couldn't be disrespected like that and
just firm it bro they probably have to
sign some form of you can't touch me
regardless of anything regardless of
what i say to you this is all for tv
purposes so i'm going to make a
restaurant live yeah but bear with we're
going to make bank but if i'm going to
be little i'm going to cuss in front of
the nation the nature's gonna think
you're a joke
just know that you can't touch my skin
once you sign this you can't touch my
skin bro there must be because some of
the [ __ ] these man have put up with
oh it has to be i'm skirted past him
nose and nose and obviously gordon's
quite tall look down at him up and down
[ __ ] off oh i just
oh
oh bro i'll send him flying
i'd send him flying and then when
everyone drags me yeah yeah i don't know
what i've done
bro that would be it oh that's a letter
leave the disrespect
oh gordon doesn't give a [ __ ] he doesn't
he doesn't
that would
make my blood
rise fam insane you'll make it fizz
fizzy that vibrant are we fizzing the
restaurant had nothing to do with this
beef as well it was all to do with the
owner versus the owner and just as he's
turned his attention to get past him
looked him up and down like he was
nothing i just [ __ ] realized you said
the restaurant manager yeah no fam oh no
any stat like passerby so just me
basically it could have been me it could
have been you could be instrumental i'm
gordon i'm beefing your owner like this
is [ __ ] [ __ ] you're just standing
there taking it i'm not even talking to
you this is
i'm out of here i turned the door's
literally there so it's literally like
this like that's how much gap there is
between our table and you that's how
much gap there is i have to slide past
you here i literally see you when you're
here scurry you feel like fam after step
and as i go nose to nose review
with the three f's [ __ ] off
i said [ __ ] off
what
that might look like who
i just work here he would have been
rattled
absolutely my blood he couldn't have
gotten him in fact his wife that night
he couldn't have gone home and [ __ ]
his wife that night belittled fam she he
was laid on her chest
her stroke in his hair and himself it's
all right and he's just feel positive or
looking up at her i don't know why he
did that i don't know why he did that
and this woman's just like you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] bro
you got
had up
by gordon ramsay
[Music]
oh tim gordon there has to be told you
the [ __ ] off with with with nothing you
didn't retaliate at all there has to be
some sort of contract outside there
signing because there's no way he's not
been banged in his face before oh
there's no way no none of them have
wanted to not bang him in his face
he's throwing [ __ ] at people oh i've
seen him
i've seen it and they do nothing he
launches pans across the kitchen and
they do nothing
nah bro not my kitchen fam not my
kitchen mad he's [ __ ] burnt
lobster thing oh [ __ ] off
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] off i would have to rock
him
i would have to
fam when i when it draws up my my
saffron risotto and he puts it in his
mouth and he like gags it out
[ __ ]
[ __ ] off
and he's like you you you here now taste
that
taste that what does it [ __ ] taste
like [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] wrong
lobs it
oh oh [ __ ] off everyone [ __ ] off go on
get out
you you go on [ __ ] off
fam all you'll hear is footsteps and
i'll just superman punch him across the
deck he'll do a backflip over the camera
[Laughter]
i can see him
over the past i could see he will
backflip over there the restaurant would
go ballistic all the celebs stop
they'll gasp he's he's done and i'm just
ranting what who
[ __ ] me yeah [ __ ] off yeah you'll be
over here i'm standing over him who's
[ __ ] off now who's [ __ ] off now
his bodyguards would drape you oh
they'll kick the [ __ ] out of me in the
alley they'll beat the piss out of me in
the alley that's probably what keeps man
humble
off cam there's mana man around here
off cam it's just bomber jackets
steel toe caps and bomber jack is about
imagine getting kicked by one of those
oh no i couldn't those worker boots bam
couldn't
couldn't i'll break my sternum couldn't
uh guys
we're here to talk about
the manscape real quick
and real fast we're gonna be in and out
um
i mean what else is there left to say
we gave you the the third generation we
give you the fourth generation we've
given you the performance package man
we've just given you
like
the best the man can get you know what i
mean
like your balls will thank you level up
but if you're still not satisfied
with the silky smooth pubes
and the
like the the almost how do i say it
gymnastic fitted
um boxes boxes
fam
they're sleepable oh they're sleepable i
love those boxes they're sleepable and
this is not even like a plug thing i
actually love those they're my favorite
boxes jesus they're my favorite 100
by far easily easily my
ah they just literally slide on bro and
they just stay and they stick it never
ride up your leg never ride up ah
because obviously
your boys are built thick down below
so when we're talking about the lunges
and stuff they they roll up i rip my
legs
just go like that
and it causes the boxers to thread up
and we've had that issue all our lives
unfortunately but um with the masking
boxes bro they stay fixed fitted oh
they're too good so when it's time to to
get down um get down with the get down
you don't have to fiddle around you
don't you don't
it's just
yeah and because they're so smooth to
the touch
your trousers fall off
when you take that belt for you yeah you
finished work fam she sounds like air
belt bucket just hits the floor bang
but yeah you guys still aren't satisfied
dust jokes we've got your weed whacker
now your weed whacker so when we're
talking man skating we're talking weed
whackers
we're talking nose
and ears yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah now
people like to play like it's not an
issue like donnie don over here he likes
to play i know his hair has never been
an issue for him visited
me
my eyes stay watering the plucky plugs
no i stay watering
sometimes you need to whack some weeds
might you and there's no shame in that
um of course not so yeah guys
if you're ready to jump in at long last
if you haven't yet i know a lot of you
have we get a lot of messages saying
that you jumped in and and we appreciate
you um
you you keep money in our pockets one
way or another and we love you for it so
keep the train moving head on over to
manscape.com
use code sng sierra november golf for 20
off and free shipping worldwide guys
that's manscape.com com
um
code is sierra november golf sng shop
for shits and gigs if you didn't know
um
we're your boys james of who had and um
yeah man let's get back to the yeah back
to the show um so yeah that's segregated
there must be mass security there
because he must be fearful yeah he must
be fearful that someone's gonna rock his
money he has to be but i think
i think probably like season one season
two he would have been like
let me test the waters let me see how
far i can push these
yeah
and he's realizing nobody's actually
going to do [ __ ] he wrapped yeah he
[ __ ] ran with it and the producers
they they lapped it up
they eat that up they said do what you
want that's this is a little theme this
is great television this is great tv and
it [ __ ] is the one i was watching was
from like 2007. oh wow yeah it's like oh
wow and i'm like i'm in it wow i'm in it
bro but now he's turned into a [ __ ] now
he does like american masterchef
and like um was it hell on wheels or
something like that he i was watching
gogglebox uh i can't remember what it
was and he was on a new
show i can't remember what the show was
called but obviously it was a cooking
show
and it was daytime tv and someone was
like oh this is a bit
below gordon ramsay daytime tv i was
like oh how to make a perfect
how to chop up the perfect pepper it was
something stupid bro
yeah he was chopping up like a green um
yellow and red one
different like dice is like other long
probably like julienned juliennes and
chocolate chips
and all this [ __ ] and
they'll watch everyone's watching like i
feel like i've seen that what the [ __ ]
is this one about yeah there's like
seven different chefs i think it's
called like
i can't remember i'm gonna butcher it
because i can't remember what it's
called there's like seven different
chefs and he walks out and they're all
like doing what he's um doing what he
did trying to chop it up and everything
and he's commentating about it
everything it's like hmm
yeah that that looks good but this one
needs a bit of work it's like big man
they're chopping peppers i feel like
i've seen that you know we're chopping
peppers out here yeah what are we on
about i've [ __ ] seen that i don't
know what it was the laughing i don't
know what it's called but i only saw it
on gogglebox yeah yeah yeah i've seen
that i'm like how is this gordon what's
why is he on this show i don't know bro
he's he's doing weird money grabs in a
minute because he's doing that like he
did that travel show with gino de campo
and that other don from first dates the
french guy uh fred saru yeah
[Applause]
i bet i did an advert for him
uh sorry i didn't yeah i was in advert
for him not for him but like for
was it for first no it wasn't for first
dates it was for
something to do obviously he does he
does first dates as well as like
culinary stuff sales for the culinary
side i can't remember what it was
specifically called but it was in
manchester this was years ago this one
is still working north asia
so it would have been like two and a
half years ago maybe three years ago he
came in well we knew he was coming in
for this thing specifically i remember
gotta trim and everything i had to make
sure i had to look good yeah yeah yeah
um
um he'll say he was going around like
four or five different restaurants in
manchester
um talking about why you're in
manchester because i think he chose
people that weren't originally from mani
okay so why did you come to manny why do
you work in hospitality in mani blah
blah blah where are your other go-to
spots apart from where you work things
like that so just asking us generic
questions
and he took some videos of like people
making cocktails and this than the other
um he said this was again this was years
ago i can't even remember whether um
where the link is for the thing but it
was
going to be posted in
you know the massive electronic
billboards in houston he said there's
going to be one on one of those yeah so
it was like a three minute four minute
video but it was gonna be like chopped
and changed and so okay it showed up
different things so yeah it was one of
those and so that was the first time i
actually obviously met that i think
first and the only time i actually met
him i say i think i know yeah that's the
only time i met him perhaps he knew who
he was through first day
yeah you kept that stump i have no idea
i feel like i did mention it but again
this was years ago yeah maybe you did
this was you i don't know maybe yeah it
was pretty cool it was pretty cool
um
all right cool
um i've got saturn for you so you know
we've been on this like twitter thread
hype
i've got a couple but go on
check this one out i got sent this
this one hurts my chest okay so
you might have seen this one you might
not have
this is
so basically
the thread is called
so it's aimed at ladies
okay and it's called
dm me the craziest story of what truly
happened when you text him saying sorry
i fell asleep
so i've not seen that but i've seen
someone
put um it was like a not a meme
someone just typed in and it was
screenshotted and put on instagram and
they and they said
type in
fell asleep sorry i fell asleep on
whatsapp and read through like the women
that i've sent it to you
and
so i was like damn that could be that
could be political and i actually did it
i typed and fell asleep on my whatsapp
and saw like the girls i've said to me
in the past oh i'm sorry i fell asleep
blah blah blah
i've seen the reasons but uh
more time more of them were exes as
opposed to
flings or like take so yeah for me it
didn't really hurt yeah but i was
looking at some of the responses they
look jokes but anyway concealer that's
what that reminded me of fan
right so this is what they were really
doing sorry i fell asleep
i told my babes
that i fell asleep early
but i'd really gone to have a male
female male threesome
i had such an amazing experience
one tool in my mouth another in the
cooch
these men really took care of me that
night
i stayed over so i was asleep for about
11 hours
no
[ __ ] way
[ __ ]
not only did she cheat she doubled down
fam spit roasting yeah
spit roasting
stayed the night
wow
i was cheating with someone who's even
his dad's age having orgasms left right
and center wow basically passed out from
how much fun i had wow woke up the next
morning and said a cute little good
morning and sorry i fell asleep whilst i
was studying
enjoyed it so much i do it regularly
and i'm even seeing mr ass eater in
about two or three hours
mr rc
my days
wow
told my baby daddy i was asleep
but i was taking the best pipe of my
life
he was ringing my phone whilst my tongue
was in this man's arse
nah brother
your face
you're getting heated for my man
it's just not on
that's just not on what
look at your face why your face like
that femme fix your face bruv
fam fix your face what we got that's
jokes
i counseled on the guy i was dating
we've been around for uh we've been in
around three months at this point and
rescheduled uh for the next night just
so i could go get my black back blown
out by a previous [ __ ] body oh god at a
hotel he was staying at i remember he
texted me like 10 p.m just chit chat and
i didn't reply to the next morning sorry
i fell asleep babe
nah babes i was busy getting stretched
out
this is horrendous stuff bro
no remorse this is malicious no remorse
what did he do to you this is malicious
ladies
walk on bro what won this is so
malicious so i was seeing this super
jealous guy he was driving um me from
another city he's driving to me from
another city
with his friend so i could meet them as
his next girl or whatever but when a guy
had i had a crush on for ages but had a
girlfriend message me declaring he's
single
i had jumped at the chance and invited
him over
i don't know if it was just the crush or
the feeling of being sneaky but the guy
rocked my world
afterwards i saw the angry text from the
jealous guy
so while sneaky link was in the shower
i sent my guy a whole video of my empty
room
this is the thing as well is that like
keeping your hose quiet is so easy for a
girl
oh for sure
so easy for a girl she could have been
so straight up and honest with the my
man yeah i said look
my man is vex
go in the shower
i just need to send him a video to make
sure so he knows that no one's here yeah
and mama would have been like come on i
don't give a [ __ ] you sure you want me
to turn the shower on it sounds kind of
loud yeah i can just sit in the living
room like
wait we'll play the part we'll play the
role
fam
that's malicious cuz
i don't think i have any messages in my
whatsapp from
x flings or or whatever well that says i
fell asleep yeah yeah let me see all of
mine well majority of mine are from exes
fell it's not for nothing
i've got nothing
literally all of mine from exes
are you sure they were a sleep fam
because i'm not i know you said about
they weren't flings or whatever but i'm
hearing baby daddy i know i know i know
i know i'm not gonna lie to you he's
bringing his boys over to meet me
[Laughter]
are you sure
i could be wrong they could have been
[ __ ] other people but it doesn't
really matter anymore now literally
doesn't i've i i remember i have had one
sorry i fell asleep that i specifically
remember
um
for sure
but she did she was on so much crud so
we had plans
for me to go over
yeah
then at like whatever time you remember
this as well yeah huh i'm assuming this
was a time ago yeah
plans um
for me to go over at a certain time yeah
at texa like 10 minutes before that time
yeah saying call i'm about to leave yeah
just to make sure that it's still on
yeah got no reply
yeah decided not to leave just as i'm
getting ready to go into bed this is
like so let's say i was supposed to go
over there at half 10.
i get a text at like half one
saying oh sorry babes fell asleep
watching [ __ ] korea
sign i was like
raw
did you
bruh
me being the [ __ ]
waste man that i was yeah
was like it's cool
i can still pass through if you want me
to
add me
ed me through i don't know if i remember
this add me
um it was
um you didn't know who it was
met them on a night out
we met them on the night out i met the
person on the night out
bang them that night i was supposed to
link them the next night
hang on hang
let me just type in my phone this is a
stupid man
so childish for [ __ ] sake everyone
said this
ah that's hilarious hang on
uh i was never getting that oh i wasn't
never getting fair play okay yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah the thing
is i clocked the first word the first
name i was thinking
sure it can't be this yeah it's a common
name yeah the second when you said the
second um well the surname i was
thinking that's not who i think
you're saying yeah you're talking about
someone else oh
you know exactly exactly exactly exactly
she could never text me i fell asleep
she could never text me i fell asleep
are you mad i'm literally rocking the
chair why do you think i was perplexed
to them i was like who
she
she could never text me i fell asleep
are you mad if i got that i fell asleep
from her i will cut my wrist
because i failed
i failed she was no offense bottom of
the barrel will only bang if i'm
absolutely desperate and have nothing
else to do
bless her cotton socks there's no way
she could text me at half one in the
morning
sorry i fell asleep and me say that's
fine
i would never tell you that i just i
don't know i would never tell you that
that's what that's what i was like
obviously you said the story and you
said the name was thinking
nah i can't be her yeah it can't be her
never never never never never never
never yeah yeah yeah yeah um but yeah
back to the point ladies you're scum you
ask um like that's just not on ladies
that's just not on your scum brav and
you're right like mandan will play it
apart if like listen my man's bailing me
off
i need to create a scene whereby he
thinks i'm alone man then we'll play the
path i'm hiding in the cupboard because
i'm gonna need to do a full apartment
tour i need to do a zoom call yeah
man will say bless if you want i will go
home like it's mine minor to me bet bet
it's done
but yeah yeah yeah yeah women would
never do that well what
call her
they
you should have thought by that before
you cheated your waistband yeah this
fall does this fell asleep thing that's
unacceptable
it's one of those taboos that every guy
always knew there was sight and shady
about the sorry i fell asleep but we
never really knew we were happy to never
really know yeah yeah yeah yeah now we
know
it's a bit it's shaky it rocks my world
a little bit it's painful yeah yeah yeah
yeah we've opened pandora's box and we
can't forget what we saw yeah we can't
close it anymore oh [ __ ] horrible
that's [ __ ] horrible that's tough
i've got a um
i've got what would you do
if i can [ __ ] find it
uh two sucks right
i got invited to a stag do in majorca a
few years ago after someone had pulled
up of going
i didn't know the lad too well but we
had mutual friends and it was all paid
for so for me it felt like a no-brainer
we took a ferry to ibiza where things
got messy resulting resulting in us
getting separated
i ended up in a hotel room banging an
older woman gang gang
fast forward to the wedding turns out
she was the bride's mum he was out on a
hendy when i before not a single word
was said
dang what would you do
i'd do exactly what he did i wouldn't
say [ __ ]
i wouldn't say [ __ ] would you
would that make you want to bank her
again yeah
after the reception
uh oh yeah how would you pattern that
how would wait
would you be
shook obviously because she has no
recollection or necessary with no
recollection she has no idea
who you are or who you are
he was invited as a third party thing
did he say yeah so he was at a stag he
wasn't he wasn't at the wedding he was
at a stag but he was invited because
someone else dropped out okay so he
wasn't on the original roster yeah yeah
so you were let's say it was you won on
original roster you got invited i was
invited to the wedding you were invited
to the wedding yeah
not the stag someone dropped out someone
dropped it i dropped out now now you're
a stag crew no now you're on the stag
crew you're all in the cruise you're on
the ferry to ibiza coincidentally
um you've met
the bride the cheese in her she's met
the bride's mum and her girl she's in a
she's on a set she's on a separate head
to this wedding to a completely
different okay
dinky winky dinky separate hand so
you've banged her now yeah you now rock
up to the actual wedding itself a week's
time two weeks time two weeks time
whatever yeah and you feel like [ __ ]
that's
my boy's
wife's mum
how are you one how are you patting a
sec how are you patting in the second
beat if you want to be again and two
do you think she would be
mortified
when she sees your face
probably because from the sounds she's
probably got a lot of like pride not
pride but like
you're the bride's mom like she's got
decorum
she don't need to see a young lad in
there that she banged in ibiza that's
just the wild side that she doesn't want
anyone else to see especially her
daughter yeah yeah so um
i would definitely try and pattern it
again
but it depends is is she married is her
husband there i don't know
obviously according to this there was no
no inclination of that but
let's say she's a single mom divorced
but that the ex-husband's there
obviously for the for the bride
divorce she's not seen anyone but
she's also one of those ones where
it's
it's sus if she's seen with a younger
guy fair play well i don't know to be
fair i'll base it on her
if i see her we make eye contact and i
can see she's mortified
i'll let her marinate in that for a few
hours oh yeah because no one's going in
yeah yeah yeah the fest let the
festivities roll
and then i will know based on
if she
like for example if she sticks with
someone and never wants to be alone for
the whole night she's not about it yeah
yeah yeah yeah if she's making glances
over
and then
goes to the bar by herself or something
like that your boy's in
it's on
it's on 100 fam if that happened to me
my dick would be so hard i know it's so
hard you love sneaky [ __ ] like that
that's why so hard so do i
i love sneaky stuff like that especially
after a few drinks i've gone in a few
proseccos few shots here and there
and she's like i'm just bro
upstairs
that's when all the laughs stop girl you
spank about you actually
go upstairs
oh you'd [ __ ]
the thing is this
i'd bang when i be far
wake up and be like jesus christ yeah
i see her at the wedding
and then i bang her again at the wedding
the next day after i've banned her
they'll get the wedding i'll be so
ashamed of you yeah yeah it's done now
like the whole the whole yeah
the whole fantasy the whole fantasy is
done
i wake up see your makeup smeared
everything and i'll be like i never want
to see you again yeah i never want to
see you again get out my room
now
pauline [ __ ] off stop it
what did i do
again
again
but yeah man um but 100 just just based
on that coincidence i would have to bang
her again i'd have to that's gang
let's go unless i did a terrible job the
first time
true then i wouldn't then i'd be the one
that don't want to be left alone
imagine imagine you banged her
but you banged her because it's one of
those ones like you're drunk bro but
you're all in the same vicinity every
like you said or like the thing said
rather
you um
you got split up from all the other boys
she kind of like swindled you whatever
you went to dream and you banged her but
you didn't really want to bang her
not even necessarily in like
um in like a forceful way but she just
wasn't for you but whiskey like yeah
whiskey dick i'm by myself by yourself
i've got nowhere else i don't know and
it was just it was just right place
i needed a place to sleep and she was
like come back do you science you sat in
do you scientifically did it yeah if i
saw her at the wedding then actually it
wasn't for you yeah i'd be sick if i saw
it the wedding then i'd be mortified
yeah i'd be sick
[ __ ] you now and i'd be looking at
himself in the middle of what's wrong
with you bro and she tries to make
advances on you she doesn't care who
sees me yeah i'd vomit
she doesn't care who sees that would be
actually strange enough that would
actually be a turn off for me mm-hmm
even if i was about an hour before if
she started making advances to me like
with her daughter about like her
family's around yeah if she's making a
divot to me i'd be thinking oh you're so
desperate my stop like you're making a
fool of yourself stop yeah yeah like i'm
20 years younger than you like what are
we doing
but anyway that's a weird one
it's cool
as long as like
everything's laid out clean yeah it's
sick
but yeah it could it could be gross
that i could really have some like
self-reflection that i need to do after
that after that second one
yeah after the second one a couple of
self-reflections the first one yeah
after the first one that you saw before
yeah yeah
yeah whatever kind of thing yeah but
yeah after the second one
out fam
that hangover the day after the wedding
oh god
she's putting on her dress from the
night before oh
don't
i wouldn't be able to look at her man
just oh god pat get out
please i can't do this bro ah kellyanne
stop how grim
ah that's hilarious
right where you going i have a um i've
got an amazing [ __ ] okay this is an
interesting one okay
okay
so this one yeah
um
hey guys i'm a big fan of the show only
podcast that i've listened to really so
anyways
i have an amazing [ __ ] for you
i recently tried putting myself out
there you know like playing the game can
i say quote unquote the game out on the
streets and stuff like that
remember breakfast not as successful as
you guys though but i do try you have no
idea how what success rate we had bro we
talked about the glory days but you
don't know what the ratio was saying
we took elves bro we also girls but
anyway
while i was doing so i met this girl who
i vibed with and said she was
comfortable uh with a long-term friends
with benefits saying
so that's cool i said so that's cool
and so one day while we were chatting i
kind of steered the conversation to
whether she was down for a threesome
and she said she was
which was great
and since uh she was the more
experienced of us both with this kind of
thing gang
might say this kind of thing
she said she'll look for someone who was
interested as well
a day passed by and she told me she'd
found someone oh wow quick work she was
down she was waiting for him to ask
and i said to tell me all about it but
it turns out she was looking for a guy
oh shocked i was waiting for that fam so
i was surprised
i wasn't really down for a female male
male
and so we talked about it and i said i
wasn't down for that she seemed dejected
at this point but still said she would
look for someone
and after a bit she said a friend of
hers would be interested and sent me a
photo of hers afterwards
and i don't want to be rude or judgey or
anything but her friend was really more
masculine than feminine seems like she
really wants to get down with another
guy
wow yeah afterwards i was a bit aloof
and dodgy since i wasn't sure if i
wanted to go down this path i don't
blame you homeboy
i made up an excuse to talk to her later
and give myself time to think i haven't
replied since am i the [ __ ] for
wanting to ghost this woman because of
how awkward it's been now hope to hear
from you guys great job with the pod
gang gang
love
goodness me um that's
tough
i want to say no you're not the [ __ ]
considering
the lack of inexperience or the lack of
experience you have in that field
um
because you already said like [ __ ]
that's her field of expertise she's the
one that's trying to find the next the
extra party to join this reason blah
blah blah you let her do all the ground
work basically
and you were just saying oh you were
just saying yes or no
so
considering
i don't know i think just considering
that alone
you trying to go still you
originally say no to the
um the extra guy and then you
and then her sending her a picture of a
masculine looking female
and you're like yeah she clearly just
wants to get
dominated by men
if she wasn't having the initial no and
she's bringing up that picture yeah i'm
done man 100 i'm done man i'm done 100
i'm done like i'm done
friends i'm sorry to cut you off and
obviously you're not there was nothing
there you guys weren't exclusive like
you like you said you guys are just
friends with benefits
nah man i'm done
i would just be honest like especially
if you're enjoying being friends with
benefits of her
i would say yo
i think we're on two different
wavelengths with this threesome thing
yeah let's just go back to normal yeah
um we can revisit this another time
to be fair she might like he said be
very dejected by that but yeah you gotta
be up front
um
i'm never a fan of
ghosting someone in general i think
that's a bit of an awesome move like no
matter what the setting is like
in her defense like you brought up the
threesome thing not her
you agreed to let her find someone and
when she's found someone you're like
i'm just gonna stop talking to this girl
all together
that's a bit harsh yeah it is it is now
that you've spelt it out like that it is
a bit harsh but
my only standpoint of i'm assuming his
only standpoint was
it's just nice field of expertise so he
had no wiggle room in that factory so
it's like oh you do the work
and then come we can we can find
anything and let's pat in it but i get
where you're coming from i do get where
you're coming from i just feel like
um
i don't know i i do agree with you but i
also agree with what i said as well
so i'm a
yeah and he didn't know what to say or
do and his only option that you could
think of was like i'm just going to have
to get out of here yeah i
just want to get out of here this is
concerning i don't have a chest
to go back to her a second time and say
that like i just don't have it in me i
just need to get out of here
all together this is scary now yeah i
don't blame you bro um
but yeah these things are gonna happen
man uh we're proud of you for shooting
your shot and trying to pattern the
threesome um these things sometimes go
well sometimes they don't this time it
didn't work out well for you man uh
neither of us have ever managed to
secure the three-way so
yeah
bro keep your chin up onto the next [ __ ]
buddy and
you never know what that might take well
try patting that one
just try patting that one true
true um
but yeah signing off
guys
we love you happy monday
um enjoy the rest of your week and head
on over to patreon or in just in time
for thursday and we will see you there
yeah man
bless love love go go
[Music]
you